christina
is in tempe arizona to start this hour
off hi christina how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
hi so um i'm 21 years old
i'm pregnant five months pregnant and
i'm currently in a
horrible auto loan i owe eighteen
thousand dollars
um four thousand dollars underwater with
a 26
interest rate you got messed over didn't
you
yes you were like desperate for a car
and closed your eyes and signed whatever
they put in front of you
uh yep i don't like it
so i guess you learned your lesson on
that go around huh
oh i did sorry what a mess what do you
make a year
um about 25 000
okay man how in the world they qualify
you for an eighteen thousand dollar
twenty six percent loan
and expected you to pay it somebody's an
idiot
oh there are shysters and they're idiots
okay
um yeah the car's got to go
obviously uh i i
wow and you said you're five months
pregnant
i am yes
okay i uh you're gonna have to come up
with the four thousand dollars to get
rid of the car
and that's probably gonna be a loan from
your credit union is your could your
family help you with that
they can yeah i just don't wanna depend
on them right now
okay i don't want you to depend on them
either but i want you out of this car
it's got to go now if we get rid of the
car what are you going to drive
um i was thinking about refinancing my
car
um paying the four thousand dollars up
front and maybe still keep the car
and maybe if i'm lucky i am able to like
lower my payments and
no a lower interest rate you have a car
you can't afford
okay it's it's ridiculous i mean you
make 25 000
a year you don't drive around in a car
that's 18 000 bucks
right it just doesn't there's no way
this makes sense it's a bad
deal so the car needs to go bye-bye
and then you're gonna have a four
thousand dollar loan and no car so we've
got to get you
a thousand bucks or something 1500 bucks
to get you a hooptie to ride around in
okay any way that is do you have any
access to any kind of a work
i hate to put the whip on your back with
you five months pregnant but
um but you're in a mess and i'd love for
you to pick up some more income to be
able to address all this
yeah um i'm working 40 hours at a dental
office right now
okay about 14
yeah do you have any access to extra
work that you can do
five months pregnant i don't
i was thinking maybe like uber or
something like that
may help yeah you won't be able to do
that if you get rid of this car and get
a 1500
car uber won't qualify you with an old
car like that
but you got to get rid of this car so um
so where's the dad um
that's working that's working um
he's going to school for emt right now
okay did i miss somehow i got the
impression you weren't married
oh no i'm not made oh okay all right
so are y'all living together yes you're
living together
okay so he's going to emt school and he
makes what
um well right now he's just working at a
grocery store but he's going to emt
school um we're just kind of living off
just minimum wage jobs right now
okay
how old is he he's 23.
okay christy
yeah i mean i think it's one of those
things where you turn
every dial that you can so what that
looks like for you christina
if you can start a side gig if you can
pick up a few extra hours doing
administrative something that's not
gonna be really hard on you
five months pregnant to create a little
bit of extra income on
your boyfriend for him to take a second
job for him to take a third job for him
to help turn the dials in the income as
well but this has to be a
team effort not just because the car is
a situation that's a strain on you but
because you both have a baby on the way
and so there's this fire under you to
get yourself financially stable
have a stable vehicle to be able to
drive your baby home from the hospital
in
so there's a more of an urgency than
there would be
otherwise if you were in this situation
with the car and we're not does it
does your boyfriend have debt i don't
know he has zero debt
that's good news okay all right i'm
gonna tell you what i'm really thinking
are you okay with that yeah okay
because i i care about you and i want
you to win i'm thinking about a 31 year
old
christina with a 10 year old child
okay and i want her to be in a really
really good place
and i think the best way for that to
happen is
for you guys to quit playing house and
be grown-ups and get married
you have a baby you're playing house and
it's time for
a young man to uh pull up his boots and
go get six freaking jobs and take care
of his family
and get rid of your stupid car and take
care of his pregnant wife
and he you all need to be married by
friday
and you guys need to get on with your
life and he needs to roll up his sleeves
man up now and and take the take the bit
in his mouth and get this
get this family taken care of because
five minutes ago i had a
pregnant fi a five-month pregnant woman
on the phone who got
messed over royally on a car stuck in it
but now i've later in the conversation i
got this young man standing here
and it's time for him to be that i got a
question for you what about emt school
is now the time for emt school with
everything they got going on or does he
pause the mt school they have to
you know that's what stuck out to me is
because his primary goal is not his
self-actualization it's feeding his wife
and his baby
well that's what stuck out to me i was
like this it's not it's not never on emt
school but maybe this isn't the time for
emt school when you've got these more
urgent things
like a baby in a car like well or maybe
you're just not home much because you're
an emt school and you're still working
40 freaking hours
right yeah and i'm okay with that too
yeah i've done that kind of stuff when i
was your age christina yeah
lots of people have done that kind of
stuff when i was your age but you're
kind of
you feel like a single mom over here
yeah and yet
over on the other side i've got this guy
standing here
and it's just weird i'm just going to
say it out loud
and so i'm going to be papa dave here
and love you and say if you were my kid
i i that that would have been my advice
to you the best way you can have an
awesome 31 year old version of you is
you guys you know
let's do this in the right order here
it's a big deal